>>Male presenter: Welcome to Authors at Google
in Cambridge. Today it's my great pleasure
to introduce one of our great
local mystery writers, a neighbor of mine
in Newton, Mass., Bill Landay. Bill is the
author of three best-selling books: Mission
Flats; The Strangler; and a huge runaway best-seller
in 2012, Defending Jacob.
He used to be an assistant District Attorney
in Middlesex County District Attorney's office
and he's gone from torturing
defendants --verbally anyway-- to torturing
readers.
I know there's at least one other reader here
today who's read this book. I sent Bill an
email after I finished reading saying,
"This book destroyed me. I am devastated.
[laughter] It is going to take me a long time
to get over this book." Our fellow reader
there will agree with me.
It's a gripping thriller about a murder committed
in a suburb of Boston, a lot like Newton,
Mass. Actually it is Newton; murder's
committed about a mile from where I live.
All the difference in the book is who the
suspect is and the relationships in the family
of the suspect. It is an extraordinary book,
if you haven't read it, you are missing a
great experience. It is my pleasure to
introduce the author, Bill Landay.
[Applause]
>>Bill Landay: Thank you. We've already been
chatting before so we'll just continue chatting,
I guess. I was a D.A. in Middlesex
and spent most of that time right down the
road at the courthouse here in Cambridge.
So it's very funny to be here because Kendall
Square for most of my life was a ruin. It
was awful. There was a lot of these blocks
had just be razed, and they were empty lots
and they sat there for decades like that.
And it was--it was strange--in fact there
was, I remember a rumor that went around that
the empty lots, and again it was blocks and
blocks and blocks of empty lots --and there
was a story that went around that Kendall
Square was where the Space Center was going
to be under
Kennedy. This was going to be Mission Control,
and instead of "Houston, we have a problem,"
it was going to be "Cambridge, we have
a problem," and then Kennedy was assassinated
and L.B.J. came in and the Kennedy family
hadn't been kind to Johnson and so he moved
the space center to Houston and that's why
those lots sat there for twenty years and
it was a story that really was too good to
check, but
I couldn't resist checking it and it's totally
not true.
[laughter]
There was apparently some Congressman from
Houston in the fifties and that's why all
that money was pulled down there and the Space
Center was going there to begin with anyway.
But it's just amazing the Kendall Square has
become what it is now. So it's funny to
be here and good to be here.
Anyway, as Jonathon said, I was a D.A. before
I was a writer. Really, I had never--I had
never really written anything before and I
got to the age of thirty and had my mid-life
crisis early and thought instead of chasing
the secretary around the desk or buying a
sports car, I would try and publish a novel.
Which seemed like an easy enough thing to
do, I mean, I think everybody who's a
reader and has been a book person has made
that mistake of thinking that writing is only
incrementally more difficult than reading
so if I can read a page in a minute then maybe
I could type one in four or five. And so you
do the math, three hundred pages times
five minutes and that's how long it takes
to write a novel, and I figured I was a smart
guy so that's how it would go for me.
Shockingly that is not how it works.
Well, so I was a prosecutor, I was working
on writing on nights and weekends. I didn't
actually start here in Cambridge, I started
out in Lowell. Middlesex County extends kind
of Northwest from here. And at the time, Lowell
was the busiest court in the county
and it was a really colorful court to be in,
too. You know, if you wanted to try cases,
it was great; if you wanted to collect
stories, it was a great place to be, also.
I remember my-, very early on there in Lowell
District Court, which is where all of the
arrests would come in for the weekend, I
remember one of the arrests was an addict
and a drunk and the story about him was he
was the only guy who ever knocked down Sugar
Ray Leonard, and he had since become a drunk
and whenever he went to a bar everybody wanted
to fight the guy who had knocked down
Sugar Ray Leonard. So whenever he went out,
he would get into these fights and would get
arrested because everyone wanted to test
him. You know, cut to twenty years later,
and, you know, Christian Bale is playing that
character and you know these stories that
were
all around me, it turns out, were every bit
as good and as colorful as they seemed to
be at the time.
There was another guy who came into Lowell
District Court, and this one I did not actually
see. He was a guy who, they said he was
a man who didn't have a mouth. He had tried
to commit suicide by, I presume, by shooting
up through the bottom of his mouth and he
flinched and blew off his jawbone and somehow
the reconstructive surgery had left him without
a mouth, but no one could really
describe to me what the man without a mouth
actually looked like and I never got to see
him. Because I was sent out for a trial.
You start off in the first session, which
is the main courtroom, and you're sent out
for trials to the outlying courtroom and so
I
missed him. So that was always in my head
though and I wound up using that guy in my
first book. There's a guy who tries to
commit suicide that way and winds up with
prosthetic jaw and that's how my first book
begins and that's kind of how all writers
work, I assume, is that you sort of--. You
gather these chestnuts as you go through your
life and you embroider them in one way or
another. And that's one reason I'm actually
kind of glad that I didn't start writing until
later in life because I had these
experiences that I could draw on.
So by the time that I got Defending Jacob,
you know, this was my third book and I had
been--. I had written a couple of crime novels
and a funny thing happens. You write a couple
of crime novels and people start calling you
a crime novelist but it never had been
my goal to be a crime novelist. I, you know,
when I look in the mirror I just see a novelist
and I was writing about crime because
they were great stories.
And that's, you know, that's really what you're
looking for is the best stories to tell, but
by that time I had moved on from the
D.A.'s office, I was probably ten years out
of the D.A.'s office by the time this began.
And so my life wasn't about crime
anymore. I remember in fact when I first left
the D.A.'s office it seemed very strange to
me that people don't think about crime.
People don't expect to be robbed and raped
and beaten. When I left, everybody that I
had met throughout the day was a victim or
a cop
or a witness, and so it seemed like this was
just an every day reality.
But most people don't think about crime, and
rightly so. Statistically you're just not
gonna be affected for the most part. And so
now I was off living in the suburbs among
people who truly didn't think about crime
very much and yet, you know, we all consume
these crime stories. It's very funny when
you think about it, that this is, this probably
our most durable genre, crime stories and
love stories.
But right now, at this particular moment,
it's all crime stories. You can't turn on
the T.V. without having a C.S.I. rerun or
a
Law and Order rerun. Novel, mystery and suspense
is the dominant genre in literature right
now. So it's funny though that, we
consume these stories in such quantity because
we, the audience, including we, the audience,
right here are very clearly an
audience of non-criminals and, I presume.
And, you know, what is it that we're seeing
in theses stories? Because a lot times I go
to these readings and it's an audience, a
traditional mystery audience looks like it's
all older women who are knitting while
I'm reading to them. It's clear they wouldn't
steal a pencil from CVS, you know?
[laughter]
And yet they're reading these books, they're
seeing something in them, something is resonating
with them. And so by the time I started
Defending Jacob, this was one of the things
that I was thinking about. Why do we read
about crime? What does it tell us about
ourselves? Why was I writing about crime?
How did I get here? So I've heard a couple
of theories about this and I started looking
into it because when I think through a problem,
when any storyteller thinks through a problem,
we think it through as a story.
And that's how Defending Jacob kind of began,
but that doesn't mean we go and--we don't
go and research the thing directly also.
One of the the more interesting formulations
that I saw about this questions is that 'good
men--bad men do what good men dream."
So that this was all sort of a way of us fantasizing
these internal desires or instincts that we
might have but that we'll never
act on. And you know there's probably something
to that, I don't know if I've found that completely
convincing, but maybe there's
something to it. Maybe there's something to
it.
Another, another idea that I thought sort
of struck closer to home was it's a way of
being exposed to danger without really being
exposed to danger. So that when we close the
book or turn off the TV or leave the movie
theater, we feel--. It's almost a kind of
relief. We say, "as bad as my day is, ordinary
as my life is, I didn't run into Hannibal
Lecter today. That's good. That makes me
feel good about where I am." And that's sort
of a,-that sort of rings true to me as well.
So, when it came time to write this book,
I had this sort of history as a prosecutor
and I'd had my newer life. By then I was
married. I have two kids, they're now eleven
and eight. This was three years ago so they
were, well, -you do the math. I'll screw up
the
math, probably. So I had these two sort of
threads of looking at human behavior, in the
courtroom and through criminal law and when
you become a parent you look really start
to look at, think about these questions of
criminal behav-- of human behavior in a more
personal way
because you want to be a good parent. You
want to do right by your kids and you want
to put them in a position to succeed. You
want your
kids to be good people. So you start thinking
about these questions of nature and nurture
and how to raise a human being and so
these were really personal questions as well
by that point.
So what you have in the story is prosecutor
who combines these two perspectives. He is
a prosecutor. He's a more senior level
prosecutor than I ever was, you would have
to stick about around ten year longer than
I did to become what Andy Barber is. And what
Andy Barber is sort of the master trial lawyer
in this office. He is the guy who tries every
murder; he's the top gun, but he's
also a dad. And he has a teenage son and the
son is sort of shadowy and reticent and very
hard to read. And so Andy is seeing
human behavior from those same two perspectives
and they're brought together when his son,
Jacob, is accused of murdering a classmate.
So that's how it begins and it turns out,
as I got into the writing of it and I was
really well into the writing of it, by the
time
this was developing. It was an interesting
moment to be thinking about what makes people
do the things they do because now that
we've decoded the human genome and we can
start looking at various physical causes for
why we might be what we are, why we
might behave the way that we do. We now have
the tools to begin to study this. And what
came up that was interesting is there are
genetic markers that are linked to certain
predispositions. Which shouldn't be surprising
at all to us, because we all know that
all kinds of talent runs in families and wouldn't
be the least bit surprising to us if a great
athlete father had a great athlete
for child; or a great musician had a great
musician for a child.
These sorts of things that we admire in people
we routinely ascribe to hard wiring. But when
it comes to the less admirable
qualities, violence, criminality, we tend
to, we tend to hold the thumb on the scale
for nurture instead of nature. And that may
be that we just like to think that we can
all be whatever we want to be and all of our
parents have told us this. "You can be anything.
You want to play major league baseball, you
can. You want to be President, you can." And
we know deep down that this isn't true.
You can't be a concert pianist if you don't
have a talent for music but no mom would ever
tell that to her child. And yet, we
like to, we like to believe that we are made
of infinite possibility and we like to not
think about the limitations of our hard
wiring.
In this case, there is a genetic mutation
that Jacob Barber carries that has been statistically
linked with a predisposition to
violence. The science in this book is true,
overwhelmingly. I fudged as little as possible
only to make the story work in small
details, but there is talk in the book about
a 'murder gene' or a 'warrior gene' and this
is a genetic mutation that has been
correlated with a predisposition to violence
and that is all true. And in fact it has begun
to find it's way into the courts. The
science is good.
There was a very interesting case--just to
digress a little bit--it involved a guy named
Jeffrey Landrigan who grew up as an orphan
in Oklahoma. Didn't know either parent, was
raised by foster parents. At around age twenty,
he was living in a trailer park and he
hanging around with friends and they were
drinking. A fist fight erupted, Landrigan
produced a knife and killed the guy he was
fighting with. He's convicted of murder in
Oklahoma. In prison in Oklahoma, he tries
to kill a fellow inmate and is convicted again
of attempted murder. Second consecutive life
sentence. He escapes from prison in Oklahoma,
makes his way all the way to Arizona where
he
commits a third murder. A truly gruesome murder
and he is given the death penalty.
He's on death row in Arizona and a fellow
inmate says, "You know, I happen to be from
Oklahoma and I've done time there and there's
an old man there who looks exactly like you."
And that's how Jeffrey Landrigan found his
father and it turned out both he and his
father have this genetic mutation, the exact
same genetic mutation that Jacob Barber carries,
the MAOA chromosome. He appeals, based
on that, in order to reduce his death penalty
sentence to life.
As we discuss in the book, when this evidence
tends to come up in book it's never to say
"I’m not guilty, let me off completely."
It's always to reduce the level of culpability
that the defendant is accused of. And that
case made it all the way to the Supreme
Court. I think it was in 2009, Clarence Thomas
wrote the decision, so you know which way
it's going. And you know he didn't really
consider the scientific evidence and that's
fine, as we discuss in the book, the courts
purposefully lag behind the science because
you don't want to especially convict somebody
but you don't want to decide either way based
on a cutting edge scientific theory
that's later disproved.
So that's kind of the way our system works,
but as we all know, this is a fast moving
science and as it develops, it's going to
be
harder and harder to exclude this sort of
evidence from the courts. It's a very interesting
moment to be looking at this
nature/nurture question because, which we've
all looked at since seventh grade. But Mark
Twain or Charles Dickens or anyone else
whose written about this couldn't really look
at the nature side. We can.
And that's a new wrinkle on this, and honestly
it's an interesting way to look at it and
I had never seen it treated in a book
before. For some reason, I think that book,
I think that novelists are a little afraid
of being on the cutting edge, too. Because
what seems like a live issue isn't going all
that novel five years from now and you're
trying to write for all eternity. You're
trying to write hundred year books, and so
we tend to stay away from those sorts of theories
except in fantasy or sci-fi.
We also tend to, we don't write about the
Internet a lot. I find the Internet is weirdly
absent from modern novels. It may just be
that we don't know how to treat it or it may
be that it's evolving so fast that we're afraid
to write about it because your book
become anachronistic almost before you can
finish it.
In fact, in this book there's some discussion
of Facebook, and this teenage boy's online
life and I had to explain in the book,
because it took me so damn long to write the
book, that Facebook looked different then
than what it is now. And at the time that
Jacob Barber's on Facebook, your aunt and
uncle and your mom and dad weren't on Facebook
and it was a place where kids could
congregate and that's obviously not true now.
And so it's very hard to capture the Internet
because it moves so fast and you're trying.
You don't want to get caught up in that,
you want to talk about the essentials of human
behavior. So the result of that, I think,
is that novelist shy away from talking
about the Internet even though it's a--obviously
a massive presence in modern life. To the
extent that novelists write about the
way we live now, that's this gaping hole in
our work. All of which have nothing to do
with Defending Jacob.
[Laughter]
A good digression.
Anyway, that's where Defending Jacob started.
It is weird that it happens in Newton where
Jonathon and I live. I'm doing my part to
depress real estate values in Newton. But
the park is real; the schools are real. You
know my kids go to school in Newton and the
descriptions of the schools are completely
accurate.
And this was another sort of thing that I
wanted to address in this, when we're talking
about we audience of non-criminals that
consume these crime stories what is it that
we're thinking about when we make that act
of projection, we project ourselves into a
story like this, is it purely a fantasy?
Because clearly the old ladies who were knitting
while they read these stories, or while they
watch Law and Order, they're not
thinking that this is going to be a story
that involves them personally. To them, and
to most people perhaps, crime happens elsewhere.
It
happens to different people, to a different
kind of people. It's not something that I
am likely to be involved in. That's every
audience member's conceit. And you know, I
wanted to close that up. I wanted to write
a story where the audience couldn't really
distance themselves from this family. Where
this was sort of an ordinary family and there
was nothing exotic about them, and this
is, this is you. This is you to the extent
that the 'you' is anybody.
It's sort of hard to say what a typical audience
member looks like so it's hard to write a
novel about an 'everyman.' So when I
designed an 'everyman,' I designed an audience,
I designed a character that looked like me.
The Barbers' home in Newton looks
suspiciously like my own. Andy Barber has
suspicious similarities to me, and that's
sort of how it works. You know, you make that
active projection with yourself first. You
imagine yourself into the story and you bring
the audience along with you. So that's how
that, how that sort of began.
And happy to take questions and talk about
the book. Have you all read the book? Or anybody
read the book?
Nobody?
Okay.
Two?
All right, it's one of those books I should
say where you have to be careful talking about
it because to give away too much really [laughter]
impacts what the readers experience of the
book. I sort of think that is one reason that
the book--. We were talking earlier why this
book has taken off the way it has. It's been
an incredible ride, it's been an outrageous
success. The day it published, it hit
number one at Barnes and Noble before lunch.
This is on the pub day. It's been really fun
and we're trying to dissect why that
might be, and I think one reason that it might
be is that it's sort of aimed at a mainstream
audience but I come from a background
of writing suspense and it's plotted suspensefully.
And I find when I read mainstream fiction
a lot, you know maybe it's that I'm Internet
addled and my attention span is as limited
as everyone else's now, I find that books
are feeling a little long. And I think they
do need to get a little shorter and they need
to take more seriously the implicit promise
that the novel is an entertainment first.
That you give me eight to ten hours of your
time, and I'll give you a reason to keep turning
the pages. That's the basic bargain that the
writer and reader make and I don't
know that a lot of mainstream novels follow
through on that. I think that this book is
plotted suspensefully and written in a more
dense and literate tone and so it sort of
falls between the stools a little bit but
to people who are used to sort of book club
books, mainstream literary fiction, it feels
faster. It feels more taut and suspenseful
and that's worked in my favor. [chuckles]
I can't say that I calculated that but it's
helped so I'll take it. I've got bills to
pay, too.
[laughter]
So, yeah, to the people who read it, you know,
any questions you have that don't give away
too much.
>>Female #1: [inaudible] Yeah.
>>Bob Landay: All right, yeah, I know it's
hard, but I've toured for this book. I can
talk for hours and say absolutely nothing
so--
[laughter]
It's an acquired skill.
>>Female #2: I will say that I read it on
vacation and I was totally a wreck afterwards.
>>Bob Landay: Oh good!
>>Female #2: I was like augh---
>>Bob Landay: You mean that in a good way,
right?
>>Female #2: Yeah.
>>Bob Landay: Yeah.
[laughter]
Yeah, it's one of those books, I think, because
it's sort of--. You know it's about family;
it's about parents and children and about
how well can parents know their kids; how
well can a husband know a wife. It's about
a family of three that all keep secrets from
each other and that all has trouble communicating
with each other. And the idea that you can't
really know even the people who are
closest to you is poignant and is hard. And
yet, it's a cliché, you know, we're all born
alone and we all die alone, and there's a
limit to how much we can connect, you know?
And that's kind of what this book touches
on and so it's an intimate feeling. But that's
sort of--. To me, that's the power of books
too. That we're sort of, we are all alone
in the end. We go through life alone no matter
how close we are to the people around us.
Books alone, novels alone, give you the ability
to step into someone else's consciousness.
All other art forms, movies, theater,
whatever it is, you are always looking at
the character from the outside. You're sitting
there passive and you're watching them, and
that mimics our experience of life. You can't
know what it's like to be me; I can't know
what it's like to be you and that's kind
of as far as we can go.
But in a book, you can transcend that. You
can slip into Andy Barber's thoughts and for
three hundred pages, you can get some
indication, some sense of what it would be
like to be him. And that is the power of books,
and that's why I'm actually optimistic
about this. I don't think, despite all the
panic, books aren't going away. This is a
very very powerful medium.
Yeah. Anyway.
[soft laughter]
>>Female #3: One of the things that I appreciated
after I started reading it was, typically
I think we, in some kind of
crime or mystery involving the legal system,
for example Law and Order and any of the other
iterations of that, you have this team
of people who are obviously very united, working
against the lone bad guy or the lone bad guy
group. But it was, like you said, you
can't ever really know anyone that intimately
and everyone is still their own person.
And you see that between the three members
of the family. They're all very distinct in
kind of their journeys through what happens.
It's not, I mean, yes, it's united in that
they all are defending Jacob, but they all
have like these internal struggles and these
different dynamics happening just very personally
for them at that time that don't transcend
the entire family. And it's not like you're
seeing this
like happy, "oh, there's going to be a good
ending and resolution because they're all
in this together." It's not like that.
And that was interesting and I think much
more realistic to me as a reader because that's
how it is. You fight with your own
family and you feel that way. You know, you
are not always on the same page for the same
reason, you might be moving in the same
direction for a number of different reasons,
but it's not just like good versus bad, you've
got all these different positions of the
chess pieces.
>>Bob Landay: Yeah, and I that's--. You know,
we've all had that experience, we're not going
to have children or siblings that are
accused of murder. We're not going to know
what that's like, but we all do know that
feeling of someone in your family doing
something you're not proud of. We've all argued
with a brother or sister, or with our mother
or whatever it is and just known
what it's like to not be proud of a family
member; to be ashamed of a family member,
whatever it is.
You know, that conflict is difficult and it's
particularly difficult where you think the
person has genuinely done something wrong.
I mean, in this case, if you were in Andy
Barber's position or the mother, Laurie Barber's
position, imagine that you did have a
child who was dangerous. You have an obligation
as a parent to support your child obviously
and to be loyal to them, but you also
have an obligation as citizen to all of your
neighbors to keep them safe as much as you
can. To uphold the law. And if you don't
live up to that obligation and your child
does do damage, to the extent that you could
have minimized that danger, you do have some
kind of moral debt there. And so these parents
are both torn in different ways and for different
reasons how about how to reconcile
that conflicting obligation. How far do you
go?
When you become a parent, it's--. It becomes
a live issue when it's just arguing with the
sibling or whatever it is. Because your
kid goes off to school and you know, when
he's catching the fly ball or bringing home
all "As" , or he's in the school play, it's
very easy to be proud and yet it is routine
that there are arguments in school that your
kid will say the mean thing. Will be the
bully, whatever it is in a given situation,
and how do you as a parent respond to that,
you know?
When my kids were born, I thought my obligation
was to be their champion and to back them.
And you quickly realize that you can't
do that. You can't be on their side every
time because you will realize that they often
misbehave. They often do something wrong
and you need to teach as well. And so there's
a conflict there and, to some extent, the
position of the Barbers as parents is just
is just the position of every parent. It's
just writ really, really large. You know most
people won't be pushed to those kind of
extremes, but--
Yeah?
>>Female #4: I wonder if this is partly the
time we're in that [inaudible] living in Newton,
I always glance at
the police report.
Bob Landay: Mmm hmm.
>>Female Speaker 4: [unintelligible]
>>Bob Landay: Do you? [Bob laughs] I never
look at that.
>>Female #4: We have seen maybe two of the
children the kids went to high school with
turn up in a domestic situation at
home where it turned into a domestic violence
situation and somebody was frightened enough
to call the cops--
>>Bob Landay: Mmm hmm.
>>Female #4:--and then the whole town sees
it. And we knew them; they were all good people,
and--
>>Bob Landay: Right, right.
>>Female #4: --seemingly to be happy people
and took good care of--
>>Bob Landay: And still may be good people--
>>Female #4: Oh, yeah.
>>Bob Landay: I mean, good people do bad things;
bad people do good things; good families produce
bad kids; bad families produce
good kids and it's just a complicated thing.
And that's why it's hard in thrillers, in
the ordinary run of the mill because the temptation
is to flatten these characters. And if
you make your villain into a monster, then
it becomes very easy to plot because it's
very easy to go after a monster. But I didn't
want that; I didn't want Jacob to be a monster.
I didn't want this to be The Bad Seed, or
The Omen, you know, where Damien has the
beady black eyes and you know, the minute
you look at those beady black eyes, that this
is the monster.
So you know, we do know these people and it's
interesting when--. I was talking with a defense
lawyer the other day because when
you're a prosecutor, it’s--. You know you
have all this expertise, but your expertise
is only in criminal law.
[audience chuckles]
So if you're going to leave the office and
not be a career prosecutor, the only place
you can go is to criminal defense. A lot of
D. D.A.s get into it because you want to wear
the white hat and you, at least, feel like
that is what you are doing. And to some extent
you are. But you quickly realize that it becomes
more complicated than that. And so I was talking
to this defense lawyer and we were
talking about just this: "Do you feel, when
you defend somebody--. Say you defended a
rapist and he gets out and he
re-offends." Serial rapists are run of the
mill, you know. And I asked him, “Would
you feel any culpability, would you feel any
guilt?" And he said, "No, not at all." And
he said, "When you get to know these people,
you start seeing them as people and you
don't say 'Well, he's a rapist,'--you say,
'He's Joe and he comes from this or that background
and he has this or that
psychological difficulty' and that makes it
very easy to defend him." And from the prosecution
side, you're always on the other side of the
courtroom and you never get that opportunity
to humanize these people.
So it's a difficult thing and again back to
this question, what makes people do what they
do? What makes us what we are? What makes
us? What is this experience of being us?
And we've all ourselves done things that we're
not proud of. We all have our little secrets,
our secret shames. To begin to
understand yourself is to accept that there
are these parts of you that are--. I don't
know if I'd say beyond your control but very
very complicated and where your motivations,
well, can't even be called motivations properly.
You might be what you are and there's
only so much you can decide to do or not do.
It's a scary thought.
Yeah?
>>Female #5: Having done this, as a writer,
what unfinished business do you have for the
next book?
[Bob laughs]
>>Bob Landay: This is it, I've answered my
questions. I can just kick back and retire
now.
>>Female #5: This would be great. If it works--
>>Bob Landay: It would be great. You know
it's funny, I don't--. First of all when I
was writing this, I never had this sense that
this is the book, this is the big break out.
This is the sum of all my business as a writer.
I just thought it was the third book.
I thought it was incrementally better; maybe
incrementally more interesting. Or at least
aimed at a broader market then what came before.
But then I hope that I should always be improving;
that I should always be getting incrementally
better. So when this book
exploded, it came as a surprise to me and
I still think of it as having nothing to with,
– your job, your growth as a artist. I don't
mean to be too highfalutin' about this, but
you're always improving along a much longer
arc in trying to get better and better and
that's some books sell a lot and some sell
a little. Has nothing to do with that steady
arc of improvement. So I kind of feel that
this is one data point here and that's here;
the sales might be up here, but the book is
where it is and, you know, I hope to keep
going.
The next book gets, and I hesitate to talk
about the next book because everything always
changes so what I tell you now, by the time
I get back to my car, could be out of date.
[laughter]
So, it's about this question of evil. What
makes people to do--? What enables people
to do the things that they do? We talk about
evil as if it's this free floating force.
We talk about it as a noun when it's really
an adjective. It's part of all of our
capability and that's kind of what I wanted
to continue exploring. This sort of, the idea
of Jacob Barber as sort one embodiment
of what our capabilities are is interesting,
and it's interesting because of his background
and his particular characteristics, but
the idea that this is some shadowy unknowable
boy with all of these influences, physical
and social, that drive him to be the things
that they are, removes him in a way from the
ordinary. And I want to, I wonder what would
happen if the ordinary, if the Barber
really brushed up against someone who was
evil and who truly was capable of this and
what would that mean? And what would they,
as
lawyers, as in Andy Barber, how would they
react to that?
And that's kind of the idea. I can't really
get into specifics, not because I'm being
cagey, but because I really don't know them.
[laughter]
And this is the great frustration of this
year is that it's been--. As much as a fun
ride that it's been being out there with
Defending Jacob, it's distracting. And it's
distracting out of proportion to the actual
time doing it. I was having this discussion
with another writer the other day about why
this throws your writing so off the rails.
And the common question that I get is, "Now
do you feel all this pressure to write a book
that's another hit?" And I kind of don't because
I feel like I'm my own harshest
critic by far and so the idea that somebody's
going to say mean things about my book, is
I promise you, they could not say meaner
things than I say to myself.
So you do want to improve though and that's
kind of where it's at. But it's been hard
having the book take off because when you
come to events like this, I stand in front
of you now and I'm the public face of an author
and you know you all look at me in a
certain way as the guy who has written this
book. And I have these pat answers, practiced
answers because I've had these conversations
before and so it's very--. It's one thing
to stand up here to be this, the public thing,
that an author is, but eventually you go back
to
your desk and the way I heard it described
by this other author was, "You're never quite
as alone at your desk as you were before."
That's because this public thing that I have
to be when I'm out publicizing the book is
the opposite of what you're trying to be
when you're at your desk. And you’re just
trying to channel these other people and trying
to be this, as open and as transparent as
you can be. You're trying to disappear and
that's hard to get back to. And the more you
do this, the more you stand up here
like the author, capitol "A", it becomes very
hard to be that mass of insecurities and sensitivity
that you need to be in order to do
this. Or at least for me. I've always wondered
about these public sort of celebrity authors,
you know, the Norman Mailer types,
who can be this celebrity author and then
immediately go to their desk and just become
the novelist again. I don't seem that
ability to throw the switch and yet I can't
go back to sort of being the guy who lived
in his mother's basement and was writing
books that nobody read, you know?
So not that it was so great to live in your
mom's basement--
[laughter]
But it's complicated. It's complicated. I
certainly haven't got it figured out.
>>Male #2: Did you actually live in your mom's
basement?
[Bob laughs]
>>Bob Landay: Not only did I live in my mom's
basement, when I got serious about this, I
used to--. I was at the D.A.'s office and
I
was working, working. I was doing it nights
and weekends and that's really hard to do,
especially with that job because it's not
like--. That's not a clock punching kind of
job, I mean, you're in or you're out. So eventually
what I would do is I would take a
leave from there and I would pull up my retirement
money and I would live on that. And I would
work and work and work until the
book either died, or the money ran out and
then I'd go back and I'd start trying cases
again.
And then as I got more serious about it, I
left there. I bartended over at Flat Top Johnny's
across the way. And that is what I would do
at night, and I would write during the day.
You should all go to Flat Top Johnny's by
the way. Have you all been? Great place,
that's the end of my plug for Flat Top Johnny's
but I do love it there. And when that wasn't
enough, yeah, I--. And this was at age
thirty-six, seven, eight, you know, I'm a
grown man moving into my mom's basement. It's
not good. When I got married, when I met
the woman who is now my wife, the mother of
my children, I was this thirty-something year
old guy living in his mom's basement.
It's even worse, I would go to cut out distractions,
she had this walk-in clos--like sweater closet,
and I would run an extension
cord from the nearest outlet and I would sit
in this closet typing on my laptop. And so
I was this shut in, you know? [chuckles]
That's kind of what I was doing, and I was
churning out manuscript after manuscript and,
yeah, so you know the idea that you from
that, from your mom's sweater closet with
an extension cord under the door to this,
is phenomenal. Though it seems to have happened
very fast, and yet, when I look at the arc
of it, I go back long before that first published
book and I go back to ten years before to
this weird guy in his mom's basement. So for
me, it's all part of a much longer story.
Yeah?
>>Female #6: I know you talk with other writers.
Can you talk a little bit about writer's groups
or whatever, did they--
>>Bob Landay: I don't know about writer groups,
honestly. I've never been in a writer's group.
I've never taken a class, any of that stuff.
Which may be why it's taken me so long to
get this together. [laughs softly]
So the writers that I meet, I meet through
events. Book events, conventions, publicity
things, book store readings, whatever it is.
And I'm always really excited to meet them.
I feel like--. Writers are like cats, you
know, they're not truly social animals. So
we're off doing this job which requires complete
solitude and yet when you come together and
you realize, "Oh my God, there's someone else
out there, in his mom's sweater closet writing--".
That is a huge comfort. So I'm always excited
to meet other authors and it's a great thing
to realize there are other people who feel
as you do. There is a whole writer's scene
out there and I'm just not part of it and
I--. It's not that I choose to be or choose
not to be, it's just not my personality so
–. I'm kind of a secretive, shy person.
So--
That's it. Alright. Thank you all for coming
and it's been fun. All right.
[Applause]